Speaker 1: All right. This is super
interesting. Yesterday on the program,
The View, there was a confrontation
between two former Trump staffers,
the very well known Kellyanne Conway, and the
slightly less well known Alyssa Farah Griffin.
They both previously worked for Trump at different
points in time. This is a complete trainwreck of
a conversation where they start going at each
other. Let's just let's just jump into it and
then we'll discuss because it is fascinating.
Speaker 5: Do you want to acknowledge something
you said last segment? I remember flying on Air
Force One in October of 2020 and two very senior
advisers to the president, David Bossie and Corey
Lewandowski, turned to me and said, we would be
winning this race if it was Kellyanne running the
campaign. So I think that there's there's some
real truth to the direction it went the second
time around and that perhaps you having a more
senior role would have changed that. But I have to
ask you something. We served together briefly in
the White House my second time. I admired you
the first time when I was working for Pence.
You were very helpful then. The second time.
Oh, the second time? No, I just met. I looked
up to you. I wasn't there in more comparable
roles. I was a more junior role the first time
I broke with the President ahead of January
six, when the big lie started being shared.
I resigned in December, December 4th, and I
spoke out after January six when I saw a violent
mob assault. The Capitol. Question in here. Yes.
Speaker 1: How how do you. Is there a question
in here? So it starts to get testy. And Kellyanne
clearly doesn't like the direction this is going.
Speaker 5: Still defend him. Do you still think
he could be a good president after he tried to
overturn our democracy? So I left three months
before you did for my children. I have four of
them. And I said, less drama, more mama. And
that's exactly what I did. I think he stayed
a whole month after the election that you were
having a problem with, but that I wanted to help
my staff with jobs. I said, I think people should
know that because I haven't seen you since you've
changed. But I want to say this to you. I just to
be clear, I didn't change. I sworn to shine here
every day. I want every situation not to Donald
Trump. I know. But, Alyssa, I know that you.
As we all did. But and I appreciate that. I think
there was a lot wrong with the 2020 campaign.
And I think in addition to that,
afterwards, your former boss,
Mark Meadows, who was a terrible chief of staff,
not matching the man, did not match the moment.
Speaker 1: Look at this. This is just everybody
pointing the finger at each other for what went
wrong. This this is the rats abandoning the ship.
Speaker 5: For a global pandemic,
a reelection campaign. Neither of these
made protests after George Floyd's murder.
He didn't match the moment at all and didn't
take it. But do you think Donald Trump matched
that? And then he allowed he allowed supplicant
after sycophant after showman to come before
the Resolute desk and promise the president.
That was the day they were going to find more
votes in Arizona, Wisconsin, Pennsylvania.
Speaker 1: So this is fascinating because
Kellyanne is basically saying it was Mark
Meadows fault that Trump ended up believing
all this stuff about the big lie. It wasn't Trump
himself. Now, of course, personal responsibility.
If Trump if this story is true, isn't it Trump's
responsibility ultimately to vet whether Mark
Meadows is really telling him the truth to her?
Speaker 5: We
only had last time I was on leave. It's always
your question. Maybe you missed it. I was on ABC
Live on January six and George STEPHANOPOULOS
and I said, people have to get out of the
capital. What are you doing there? Why have
you reached the capital? What is going on?
But you were hope you're still supporting
Donald Trump. Go live on January six.
Alyssa, if you're saying that somehow
you think we're supposed to think that
you've seen the light and not just see
your name in lights, that's not fair.
We're not answering the question. What do
you hear, President, if he he's not your
president, Joe Biden. I know. But you're you're
talking about maybe a second term. You've never
denounced Donald Trump. That's when he incited a
violent mob that he did that day. First of all,
I didn't. And then you went right back to. So what
we're going to do right now is we're going to move
on because we're going to take a break. Do me
a favor. Do me a favor, because we don't have
as much time as we did. So Amazon is trying to
do this is like working with Kellyanne Conway.
Go on, baby. Joe's on January six.
Joe, get the hell out. Question I
don't want the 7 million. We're going.
Speaker 4: To go if you don't if you.
Speaker 5: Can't let her do the question. Okay.
But it's just really a follow up to that question.
Speaker 1: So a complete and
total train wreck. And listen,
there is a lot of kind of posturing here. In her
new book, Kellyanne Conway Levi's, some tell some
complicated stories about her involvement.
And everybody now is essentially trying to
rewrite history in the way that most advantages
them. But what is very clear is that everybody's
pointing fingers at each other and just a complete
train wreck of a new episode. Interesting to see